hello rejects hey there my name Greg my
name John we can of horror edition why
not do this one then top 10 horror
movies might be a lengthy video because
there's two of us here we're going to go
through this as fast as possible without
going to too much review but let's kick
it off I'll start first okay now John
definitely has some honorable mentions
he'll mention at the end and I want to
start off when it would come when
composing my list I just went off of
okay I've seen so many [ __ ] horror
films in the past 25 years and there's
been a lot of horror movies in the past
25 years and movies before I was ever
born so I just went off of like
primarily memory of what our films up
just after so many years of watching
films and films I haven't seen in years
like what really do I love what still
sticks with me our choices are more just
emotional based yeah more so than
logical but we know there's films that
are probably scarier than some of the
phones we listed but it's not about that
for us it's more about the love that we
have for these films yeah if I'm making
a top-10 part of it what I enjoy watch
and the experience so the first one I
put for a my number 10 is the shiny oh
yeah
The Shining is what is the masterful
film of dread to me bread is not my
favorite kind of horror because it's not
like a fun experience it's rather
unsettling but there's something so
admirable at the shining because more
for me than the Exorcist honestly of how
it's a true film it's not it's it is
horror primarily throughout but it's
still like a great film where as opposed
I felt like The Exorcist sort of hops in
and out of drama and then horror than
drama that or there's a constant sense
of horror throughout yet it's just an
outstanding film and it features one of
the you know best Jack Nicholson
performances ever and also like
incredibly quotable to me it's one of
the most definitive and inspiring horror
films I've ever seen since if this
didn't make my list but here you talk
about it is making me one watch it again
because I think the shining is is it's
your item in film of psychological
madness to me yeah it totally it
and so yeah when I approached this list
you know I take a lot of things into my
top ten for me I want to be diverse but
I also want to be you know kind of a
balance of the objective in the subject
of each of these films has something
that I really appreciate or I love or I
just really enjoy watching and think is
worthwhile so my number 10 is a bit of
an oddball
I chose beyond the black rainbow which
is this weird little film that came out
a few years ago by the son of George
cosmatos it's a pretty good pretty you
know prolific Hollywood director and
it's this surreal sci-fi horror thing
and it's so hard to describe but ever
since the first time I saw it it really
stuck with me and it's horrifying and
ready and surreal and beautiful and
strange and it has those kind of Kubrick
elements because of how you know
symmetrical and and distinct all the
designs are and it's obtuse and weird
yeah it's just unlike any other film
I've ever seen and there's definitely I
love horror and a lot of dread and a lot
of weird body stuff in it it's kind of
horrifying on so many levels but it's
also super hypnotic and compelling this
is just a movie that stuck with me ever
since the first time I saw it and I and
I wanted to include it on this list to
kind of fill that what the [ __ ] quotient
yeah that's how that maybe is to me and
I loved it
so for my number nine I chose the film
Shaun of the Dead it's a horror comedy
for sure I'm gonna coop with you because
it's made my list - okay let's just coop
number number nine okay Shaun of the
Dead for our number nine we chose Shaun
of the Dead because it's a horror comedy
it's more of a comedy than a horror film
to me but the horror is such an
important element to it this could have
easily just been a comedy but they
really went out of their way to infuse
classic zombie thrills in there while
also being a satire a spoof in some
parts of a zombie film but also honors
like good Gore at times it encompasses
everything we love about zombie films
not just making fun of it but just
making it part of the making comedy a
part of its world oh yeah I mean it's
got it's got tons of wit and heart and
stuff like that like the humor is all
very natural and it's just about like a
different group of people in a zombie
apocalypse you know you would have just
a fun group of friends experiencing this
situation - and
the magic of Shana dead is that it's
shot like a zombie film its shot laughs
horribly uses those techniques
especially that scene where David gets
torn apart like that is straight out of
a Romero movie like where they're just
digging into his torso and every it's
mob of people pulling out guts that
movie does kind of nail you can tell the
people who made this love these movies
and know these movie's a mess and it's
got so much style but it's also got
heart and it's also just a well made
well acid is a very witty film
yeah totally like that that was a
formative movie for me too because that
that came around when I was really
starting to dive deep my next choice not
eight
I appreciate like family or like family
that look horror that you could watch no
matter how old you are and a movie I saw
that I loved was ParaNorman which is you
know a like a movie it's claymation and
it is kind of a weird little zombie
ghost movie Terry Gilliam show you
totally teri
uh but you know like paranormal really
dazzled me because again it's the
beautiful animation style and it's a
movie kind of about the kind of kid who
loves horror movies and if you're like
us you know loving that you know you can
relate but it also has a great message
about fear and that's a sophisticated
thing to me now because you know a lot
of animated movies come out and and the
idea that you should be yourself and
believe in you and all that and be
individual is good but ParaNorman has a
really great discussion of what fear
does to us it's a horror movie about the
concept of fear and what it does to
people but it's also got a big
imagination and a lot of heart and a lot
of humor so I I love that movie and it's
one I pull out you know every Halloween
time I pull out every hole okay
just good say that enjoy my next choice
is aliens this odd alien aliens
James cameras version and some people
might prefer in terms of like a horror
film must know my credit the first alien
to be more of a horror film
I like aliens significantly more I think
it has a cool blend of not just horror
but one of my favorite things of Horrors
when they cross John Rah's and this to
me crosses the genres of science fiction
and action films on top of that two
really great character with a bunch of
different characters in there you get
member form system Sigourney Weaver
Michael Biehn
Lance Erikson Henriksen Eriksson and
heresy Paul Reiser Paul Reiser Phil you
look paul reiser bid that oh yeah in
terms of a sequel it really topped the
first one for me because I think it has
the great elements of the first alien
hey the first thing was a much slower
film had a lot of tension it's very
specific kind of mood and atmosphere and
I felt that James Cameron with the
sequel for aliens I felt he honored that
but also managed to include these other
elements bringing an even more enjoyable
film a much more balanced film of
several different tones and you get I
just think you get so much more out of
that film it's such an awesome
experience of ass-kicking
back to it oh my god it's a scary you
know that's a film that I saw when I was
young every time I revisited it gets
better and better and cooler and cooler
and yeah to me that's one of James
Cameron's all-time best films right
after right I would say that's like
Terminator 2 and that or as best films
for me yeah it seems like a like a
ferris or an avatar everyone loves and
loves efforts are for my Narae I'm going
classic man I'm gonna I'm go back I
debated this one it's a wonderful life
use yeah it's horri what if you weren't
actually existing anymore that's heron
terrifying so I didn't know who you are
so fat angels talking to you people up
in the sky are concerned with your life
and send a dude to leave not a good it's
a scary Ferris scary Christmas mood and
I debated over this because there are
only 10 slots and these lists are really
hard for me to make but I'm going with
Todd Browning's film freaks freaks is a
movie so I was just reading up on that
film I love freaks a lot I almost want a
night of the Living Dead which i think
is terrific and I genuinely loved that
movie - but freaks has something special
to me and today I feel like freaks makes
the list it's just a unique experience
of a movie it takes place in a carnival
and they have a cast that's assembled of
real carnival performers real people
with these strange maladies and
deformations and whatnot and it tells a
really compelling story inside of that
about what it is to be a freak and you
see this little community and it's like
the community in and of itself
you know they thrive they have each
others
that means the normal people who you
know are really the freaks so to speak
and this ruined Todd Browning's career
that time it also inspired American
Horror Story freak show without a doubt
it is very much an inspiration for that
that's a huge love letter but yeah this
movie like it's just a fascinating movie
and it's got a compelling little story
to tell
yeah it's just when I pull out you know
when especially when Halloween time
rolls around like I definitely when I
want to watch something old-school you
know go back to the black-and-white film
era you know like that's a movie I
definitely reach for for yeah besides
talking about the love and experience
and one of the films that like truly
terrify me in the theaters is my next is
uh 28 days later oh oh yeah I debated
really hard about keeping that yeah this
film has it's like political allegories
and it's but it beyond that though it's
just one hell of a unique experience
especially in the theaters I remember
the first time I saw that movie I used
to go to church every Sunday and I saw
like a little trailer for it and I was
like that's got some good reviews hey
mom you want to watch it I must have
been like 10 or 11 at the second just
movie with my mom and I saw it in the
theaters kid you know my mom went to go
get popcorn yeah I go in the feeder it's
packed I have to sit somewhere alone she
walks in with like this big box of
popcorn and like two giant sodas to see
Killian Murphy's penis I'm screwed
like it's the first thing she's yes and
she's looking around like where's my son
dick on the screen and I can't find that
is not a situation I wanted to be in
today but that was a film that truly
terrified me I haven't revisited in a
long time but the reason this is on my
list was because of the experiences
generated for me when I was in the
theater I was really on the edge of my
seat
visually nothing like it had been done
yet nothing had been done by any loyal
man he's got a distinct yeah I an ear
too cuz music plays in heavily and
there's some iconic scenes set to music
and introduced Cillian Murphy's the
mainstream and this film was a very
loosely definition of a great [ __ ] I'm
like one of those very low-budget flicks
that managed to get such huge popularity
because of how [ __ ] terrifying
one it was a great twist on zombie film
the zombies ran they like it was scary
yeah I mean using the contagion element
you know really makes it scared it
brings it into a more realistic more
modern scientific and you turn into a
zombie really fast in the film yeah like
that one scene where the dad gets the
idea of the I of the film also managed
to be very emotionally heartbreaking it
with without films like 28 days later
like ik some great zombie films from of
the Romero days but I feel like because
of 28 days later we get stuff like The
Walking Dead now because that really had
a strong emotional like a real emotional
pull in the zombie apocalyptic landscape
Alex Garland and Danny Boyle are our
great team and you had a great cast too
cuz like that movie takes the zombie
apocalypse and and really extrapolated
it further than I think we had been used
to seeing at the time like when they get
to that compound where Christopher
Eccleston is and they're trying to
repopulate the world and all that stuff
like there's some sinister [ __ ] and now
we're used to like you said walking dead
now we're used to the whole like ah it's
really the humans that have monsters in
the zombie apocalypse that brought it in
a really both fresh and really
horrifying way cuz the things they're
trying to do or just soaps
so my next movie my number whatever this
is 7 I had a hard time picking cuz I
love Rob Zombie movies and depending on
the day I can plug any one of Robbie's
movies into this slot and you know I
almost went with Halloween for reasons I
can explain but later but I'm gonna go
with Devil's Rejects just because I
wanted to include I do like IR I
contemplated putting it on my list who I
really wanted to I have a taste for ugly
movies sometimes sometimes I like a dark
exploration of things that aren't
necessarily pretty and that are
challenging in and of themselves and Rob
Zombie makes these movies where
everything is a challenge and I
appreciate the way he does it I like his
eye I like his aesthetic again depending
on the day this slot could have been
Lords of Salem this lot could have been
Halloween this lot could have been House
of thousand corpses I debated hard but
the Devil's Rejects to me I think is
just succinctly just as a as a film
there's not much I would change about it
it's compelling it does interesting
things with just the concept of human
horror
I actually wish I put some I live I
think we can make a new one yeah uh but
yeah this this movie really like human
horror is the stuff that really disturbs
and scares me and while you do have the
Firefly plan that are over-the-top
they're over-the-top but they fit the
world that they're in they're iconic
characters and then you have it's
sheriff Waddell you have his story you
know going after them and the way they
interplay everybody talks about you know
the way they interplay with who is the
villain anymore and kind of it's
everybody brilliant and it's alright I
saw that here's my mom's you know it's
good tylium I'm on board for watch this
like ever the first half it's like the
devil's the rejects are the bad guys
they are badly fill up these people
these they're terrible by the end of the
film like they don't do anything that's
really like redeeming movie by the end
of the film though when they're like
tied up and the sheriff has them you
know like holy [ __ ] I I don't want them
to die now that's an interesting thing
to play it plays with cruelty in the
most interesting way because where do
you as a human if you see a situation
where do you start to simply eyes and
when he's like nailing them to chairs
and stuff you're like this isn't getting
any better like this also leads to more
proof to me it's his most visually
impressive film I mean granted I'm the
only film have a scene of his Lords of
Salem Oh
but now but it turns though that's his
most visually impressive I could see
that and like just based off the
trailers why someone might say that to
me Devil's Rejects was his defining
style that was yet I was like this is
the Rob Zombie style now because they
separate for a lot of people forget
Devil's Rejects is a sequel because it's
so different looking yeah than the first
one and I thought that was such a great
approach to take let's take the same
characters and just throw them in a
different kind of world you know yes
let's hear out of their home into them
into the world when they're fugitives
well let's make the story about them
instead of people who ran into and that
was like that that was like the dawn of
movies at that time one of the few that
were coming out were like let's make
this all handheld and need to feel real
back exploits yeah yeah cuz I remember
feeling like this a true story like the
yeah not is this a documentary but is
this based on a true story
I remember thinking that when I first
watched it yeah man and I'll say today's
great - he's great bill Mosley is great
even sharing like sherry moon is really
good as baby Firefly always Rob Zombie
does really great stuff with music in
his movies I think and you know you've
got that iconic free bird scene yeah
it's the free bird sea and like it's
amazing like it's earth to me it's
amazing you know and there's a moment
like that in every one of his movies but
I think for the top 10 I think it's
doubles rejects all right Wow okay no I
contributed my next pick was was a film
that from a director that people are
starting to kind of like again which I'm
happy to hear because for a while he was
like the most hated director M night
Shyamalan is the sixth sense the sixth
sense I I think people sometimes forget
just how great that film is like every
once in a while I revisit that film and
then when I revisit them like this is
one of Bruce Willis's best performances
ever Haley Joel Osment was amazing in it
fantastic it was it was a different kind
of ghost movie and it also had one of
the most memorable twists of all time
yeah that's one of those twists for
you're like what the [ __ ] didn't how did
I yeah yeah my mom I was watching at
home my mom is involved all my horror
movies my mom like came home when the
middle of me watching and she had seen
it before and I never watched it and
then she's like you know Bruce Willis
dies like she says that oh and I'd like
you ruined the movie and then the twist
comes and I'm like who's dead the whole
time yeah I was having fun with it to us
there we had the court of all I see dead
people line like what it was also no Maj
the ghost films as well like oh when
you're cold that means through you and
all that it when that did something
interesting because like it may go scary
for kind of a different reasons like
ghosts seeing ghosts is just this thing
that call has to live with he just lives
has to live with this horrifying thing
all the time it doesn't feel like every
other haunted house mover it's like oh
the ghosts are gonna kill us
ya know like it's it's not a haunting
movie Z you discover halfway like maybe
like a little bit more than halfway
through that
oh he's not necessarily being haunted
he's being asked for help
yeah this
child is another cool thing that had a
heart to it it makes it different yeah
it makes it fresh this child has to live
with that kid walks to the rooms like
the back of his head blown up and you're
like this is a kid West yeah with this
during his daily life like that must be
a horrifying existence I already spent
like six years working on that script
and it really paid off and I still think
he hasn't noticed it was great I mean
look some people really love unbreakable
but I still think the sixth sense is
still his best film he's ever done I
hear great things about split so far so
I'm very excited to see what happens
next like I hope I hope he can bring it
back my next one uh is a movie I know we
both like I'm going with Evil Dead 2
people dead - uh you know we we borrow a
lot from Sam Raimi you know we were
clearly influenced by he lets us borrow
his car sometimes yeah you know he'll
give us money for coffee and things like
that drop us off places when we need to
go to the movies pick us up before
curfew you know we borrow things from
Sam yeah evil did - I probably see an
army of Darkness like the most times and
there's stuff I really appreciate about
the first Evil Dead that I think are
special to that movie but evil in two is
is everything you know it's like it's
still scary but it's still zany and
crazy and and hilarious at times you
have the iconic Bruce Campbell who we
love Bruce Campbell it's a fantastic you
know perfect blend that creates that Sam
Raimi's style tops the first one it does
it does yeah yeah there's stuff I I do
really appreciate about the first one
that only that movie has because of how
scrappy it isn't loaf I like I admire
the first one because it's so jarring I
think's real I think the first one's
scarier in terms of dread and town and
it is like evil haunting and it assaults
you in different ways yeah like I said
like it's so shrill and that always
really charged me about that movie like
the demons won't shut up but the second
one though is Sam Raimi's definitive
style yes yeah that's one like we got to
it like just because he had a budget he
did more than just make it better
looking he had it a whole new flavor
- yeah and tons of imagination it's a
cabin in the woods demons movie but with
crazy stuff that happens and that's
that's the stuff that excites me about
horror especially is when people get
and you've got an ash growing out of a
different way so yeah like you know it's
it's it's fantastic I love that movie my
next movie is something that's probably
gonna piss off the YouTube world
um because for some reason it's one of
those things that people on YouTube just
tend to not like but like I said I'm
going off of experience here and I'm
honestly putting this on my list and
probably I think it's number five uh
Erin normal activity okay a lot of
people appliquéd i remember that movie
first came out that was definitely like
the next Blair Witch in terms of people
going is this real life that's a real
film but I remember watching that film
and being genuinely terrified in the
theaters it was a great word-of-mouth
experience because I went to the
theaters and I was at my girlfriend at
the time I remember saying to her like
did you ever watch a trailer and she
said no and then it people in front of
me next to me behind me all heard me
asset and they're all like I didn't
realize I don't know this about yeah
that was a great sign that like this
must be a really scary film if so many
people are going to watch this film yeah
and no one's even watched the trailer
for it and I thought it was one of the
great exercises and low-budget
techniques and relied solely on the
performances of these two people who
haven't really done anything else
besides those films even if you don't
find it terrifying I still think there's
plenty to admire in it oh you see that's
what I appreciate about this movies I
wish I had your experience watching it
because I saw it like alone in the
theater like right before it left like
when the hype had come and that was what
I left with mostly I was like I really
appreciate that movie for what it does I
don't love Paranormal Activity the
franchise that movie is really
impressive for what they were able to
achieve on like $11,000 yeah you know
like there's some convincing gags it
takes its time and it does have kind of
a chilling vibes
it has a great build-up pod to tell it
because I first feel like I don't know
where this is going then [ __ ] starts
happening like those memorable moments
where she gets pulled off of her bed and
it's done it looks real when did he do
it yeah I thought that I I thought that
was such a great experience in the
theaters and even though as time passes
I could see more of its flaws as I get
older I still won't ever forget that
first time I saw that phone
ah see I wish I could have had that
experience I do I'm gonna mix in a
little sci-fi okay this is my other
sci-fi my more traditional sci-fi I love
the thing I debated hard on which John
Carpenter movie to include on this list
cuz he's made some great movies some
movies I love it he's like the most
remade director or history but the thing
is a movie that that I adore each time
I've seen it I mean that's a it's it's a
desolate you know dready it's with
all-time definitive films of practical
effects - totally Rob Cortines effects
are ridiculous and just yeah again the
imagination of scope and seeing the
human form distorted and twisted up and
the paranoia that that brings when you
know nobody knows who the thing is and
everyone around you is suspect and
hearing now especially uh now that there
are no collectors editions out and like
the way they shot things like they
didn't give anybody I liked if they were
the thing which is like a neat little
trick so it's like it's a really
creative isolated movie and it Kurt
[ __ ] Russell
yeah and Keith David and like it's got a
great cast it's really suspenseful the
music is sparse but great I love a good
alien horror movie and there's a great
environment to set it in mm-hmm
yeah it's a total yes horrid this is you
know we don't see much and like this is
like as isolated yeah yeah you're in the
Arctic like what people didn't have cell
phones back then and stuff yeah you got
a chopper and that's it yeah a chopper
in a computer that plays if you're lucky
enough to fly it in the blizzard yeah
yeah and as yeah it's just it's so
creative and it's also a good example of
how remakes can work really really well
and that's something people forget that
that's a remake yeah yeah the Howard
Hawks movie thing from it does that
became a more definitive film than the
original yeah and it takes you Riddler
argue that but that's what I think
though it's no yeah I think people do
kind of look back at the at the 82 film
is as the one you know the after
surprise you know they saw an
opportunity to go hey this is a cool
idea but we can do something a little
bit crazier with it it works really
really well all right so my next pick um
sometimes you know like John and I
actually attempted doing
this list last year it was like all my
movies were totally different I feel
like every year my list is gonna change
just based off what my feelings are at
at the time till no but this year for
the my next one I'm putting
trick-or-treat down yeah that's my new
treat we okay so we've got that one
together trick-or-treat we saw together
we saw it in the feeders which we were
so fortunate to do because it got
straight to DVD release which it
shouldn't have gotten I know like they
had been postponing that film for so
long I heard Brian singer was producing
it and so I really wanted to watch this
we went to one of those like advanced
screenings like a year after it was done
beautiful though this was the year too I
always remember this when we saw this
and this is what makes it so magical to
me is it's the year didn't feel like
Halloween until two days after when oh
yes I responded in November yeah not on
November the second I had no idea what
to expect and I had yet not anything
like this
I don't think yet I have aa Creepshow I
forgot about Creepshow I could have put
death okay whatever but if yeah it was a
big fan of Creepshow growing up and then
watching this was like home I got
another kind of creep show kind of films
this to me though was different because
this also picked this this is a love
letter to Halloween it's one of the few
like horror movies that actually takes
place on Halloween too it also pays
tribute to all kinds of different horror
genres you got the serial killers amid
oh the vampires the ghosts the
werewolves you got all kinds of
different stories in there and they're
all intertwined in a very neat way in
this in this one community and I talked
about - it's scary film but it's also a
ton of fun I I hadn't I don't think I
it's other than the next movie I have on
my list I can't think of another film
where I was just hopping back and forth
between terror and laughter yes so
consistently throughout one that like
there's every kind of character in this
movies there's you know no matter who
you are I think you can latch on to
somebody and they have a lot of creative
little ideas like they're werewolves are
really cool and it has this disturbing
when they turn into werewolves skins
okay yeah totally and it's got this
twisted sense of humor like it does feel
like Halloween it's got a Halloween vibe
it's got trick'd yeah
in its DNA and it has a personification
of the Halloween spirit that just seems
like it's perfect like the Sam is a
perfect character to me you got Dylan
Dylan Baker Dylan Baker yes
Baker like Bryan coddling up that kid
and you're like I know I shouldn't be
laughing but there's something kind I
think I'm worried but yeah just trying
to bury him in the backyard yeah Brian
Cox keeps bothering yeah
and then uh Sam you thought isn't Sam
the the pumpkin head Yeah right like
that was such a nice line because that
was the one element they infused that's
like this isn't serial killer or
anything you've seen before this is our
our definitive thing in trick-or-treat
or the thing we created for sure and
that was Sam and Sam was really cool Sam
was awesome and and Sam has again that
that Halloween spirit and I love that
there is a movie like this that is tied
into Halloween directly because that's
important to me like I like a good
Halloween horror movie that's a
sub-genre to me like they created an
iconic character without even it seemed
like without even trying and this movie
like again yeah like you said it got
shoved onto DVD because nobody want to
compete with saw and Paranormal Activity
I'm gonna create a following and it got
a following and now Sam is like on it
yeah yeah it got a great following yeah
and I couldn't think of a better you
know character to attain that's I can
see you like I could see a studio being
like I don't know how to market this but
oh that's at the same time though it's
still like what you watch it it's a
fantastic experience I think it helped
open the door but it hit just before the
anthology boom you know yeah before we
started getting like the HS and all
these different things but my next one
it's kind of similar in the sort of
similar reasons but different reasons
that I'll go into drag me to hell
that's another it's like us Italia like
this list is mainly from experience of
watching films and drag me to hell was
another one where all I knew was we saw
his own together to Sam Raimi directed
it
we saw it advanced screening not not
everything was fully done and post yet
but still managed to be you [ __ ]
tariffs I think it's way better if you
never see
trailer this was another one of those
where I didn't know what to expect we
just this was when we were just going to
lots of these screenings and this was
another same kind of jump like I didn't
know and this was a very meaningful film
because this is right after Sam Raimi
did spider-man 3 and this was him going
all right I'm gonna step away from the
big movies I'm gonna do something
smaller oftentimes directors will do
that but not all the time do they
greatly succeed this one has a high
tomato score audience loved yeah yeah
audiences loved it it's hysterical it's
campy it's frightening Alison Lohman is
great because she doesn't go all Bruce
Campbell on us but she's eight what Sam
Raimi still allowed us to get a female
heroine that still got a kick-ass by the
end but still got what like she had
coming by the end of the film I just
love the way it plays out especially by
did the final shot of that movie um well
like I mean hopefully spoiler uh but
when because Justin long the whole time
he's just has supported a supportive
boyfriend yeah and he's like look I know
you're going through [ __ ] I'm gonna
support you money's money so here's some
money you know but then in that moment
when he sees her dragged to hell and you
just see his expression yeah like oh my
god like he's realizing so much linic
dragon I had to know like man the crowd
went in an uproar of applause that was
one hell of an experience and the old
lady the old lady is an American woman
really
yeah I saw interviews with her years
down the road I was like who is this
actress because this this was a
character you know like when you're
younger you see movies I'd like kind of
haunt you when you're alone and this was
one of those experiences where this old
lady kept [ __ ] imagining she was
gonna appear somewhere she keeps scaring
the [ __ ] out of me and then I looked her
up cuz I'm like I just gotta see the
actresses that way I could stop being so
[ __ ] terrified of this fictional
character and then find out this is an
American woman totally putting on like
an accent body language and everything
it was a gypsy total character
transformation I thought they hired a
foreign actress to be in it oh yeah I
mean this this movie is a very worthy
choice I would have put it on my list if
there were more slots and Sam Rayette
coming back and proven like he's still
got it and he's got
in spades because like this is the most
I think I have both left and then coward
and jumped in the same you know
oscillating cycle sometimes at the same
time like this
I didn't bounce off that real quick will
quack real quick jump scares are a thing
that are so complained about this movie
has some of the best chairs somewhat
like throughout there's like genuinely
great jump scares in this in this film
like you can hear Sam Raimi giggling
through the skin like that that's how
much spirit this movie has and like it's
gross it's dread II it's weird and culty
at times like it's it's drag me to hell
it's a movie called dragon apple like
that's what this movie there's also like
fast paced fun you know
yeah totally like it literally is kind
of everything is you know maybe like I'm
of the category is ready
you gotta usually have like slow
building this was like really fast into
this role like man that was something
else oh yeah my next movie I chose the
original Texas Chainsaw Massacre Biel
jessooka vani know I like to do dozens
reversion but the original one from the
70s is uh uh might be a perfect film in
my eyes like I see that movie especially
having seen it a couple times in the big
screen now like help teach me what
people love about the 70s so much cuz
that movie feels real like it feels like
you're just kind of out on a day with
other people it's not no it's not you're
kind of out on a date with these people
you can feel how hot and sticky it is
and stuff just kind of happens and just
the stuff that happens happens to be
horrific yeah you know and it unfolds in
a really natural way the music is really
strange
the characters are believable and it's
one of those movies I think that's you
remember it more violent than it really
is because it is horrifying weird
backwoods movie and when they're getting
right down to the terror and stuff like
that especially when Sally is at the
dinner table
it's just hysteria and I think it's a
masterfully made horror movie and it
makes me feel that way every time I want
just has some of those best like you
know 70 shots that like films like the
Kanye paid homage to of like far away
and then slowly zooming in her
- zooming in yeah yeah some really
creative shots and set designs and you
know there's only bones everywhere and
it's just like it really feels like a
natural movie my next one is actually a
foreign film and like an idiot I've
totally forgot to look up again whereas
from I think it's Swedish
let the right one in this was a totally
different kind of vampire film that I
had ever seen I fell in love with this
movie it's not the scariest film I mean
even seen I have not oh man you are
missing a happiness now I know I saw the
trailer uh the TV show they showed once
of like the girl looking some blood and
the boy being like what the [ __ ] is
going on but then I saw the movie I
decided to check it out her the song I
was getting great reviews I went to the
Laemmle and watched it and I fell in
love with it it it's a story about a 12
year old girl who's a vampire I mean
she's not like 12 years old anymore she
just stays in that form yeah and then
you got a 12 year old boy who's bullied
and it deals with these themes of
bullying and friendship companions
standing up for each other it has then
family all these different themes all
circled around this one vampire story
that has its moments of Terror has some
great visuals in there there's some
violent moments in there or just like
when a bit like the last night I don't
want to give it away but the last
violent moment you're like smiling is
like this this movie was so good that
when they remade it in America it was
practically shot-for-shot remake how do
we do it
we just got it same exact I would have
no way to top it it was practically the
same exact film just in with different
actors and in English that phone was one
film that like that rare horror film
where I walk away from it and I
genuinely feel good after it's done
interest yeah I felt like I loved I I
loved that movie like I loved it
probably my number one why should I put
that summer one my number one is is just
my ranking is loose it's always gonna
change but this is my number one movie
this is my favorite movie of all time
and it's not a it's not like a
straightforward horror movie but Tim
Burton's Ed Wood from 1994 that deals in
the realm before yeah it's all about
wirdy wood jr. the guy who made you know
the storied worst film of all time plan
9 from outer space you made a lot of you
know flow budget horror movies and nudie
movies and stuff like that this movie is
is my favorite for so many reasons I
mean it's got such a genuine Johnny Depp
performance like that's a really great
acting performance to me from Hello
Lugosi yeah like he really resonates
with me in that movie and that movie is
steeped in it's like a biopic that's
shot in the style of the movies that guy
would make you look at you bio baixa did
yes you get Bela - and so it has all
these horror movie elements it's shot in
black and white it has all these you
know bits and pieces it's assembled of
the bits and pieces that made up those
old movies and for that reason I still
regard it as you know fitting in with
the horror because yeah they're all
these scenes were there making horror
movies where these strange things are
happening it gets a little bit surreal
your main characters are people like a
Lugosi Vampira and like every time I
watching it I feel you know kind of
October II it's a movie about movies
it's a movie about the love and passion
for you know horror and things like that
you know in a loose way and it's looking
more land out martin landau is amazing
like there's some great performances in
here
yeah just every time i see that movie my
heart swells up and i just think it's a
terrific film if you haven't seen i
think it it's probably one of Tim
Burton's very best that's one of the
times when [ __ ] like Tim Byrne and
Johnny Depp cared didn't care to be
different and be unique and not try to
be the main street they just cared about
what they were doing yeah it's it's a
wholly creative movie to me because it
draws from reality but it really takes
advantage of the fact that it is a movie
yeah and it feels like those movies it
has these horror revives it's it's got a
really crisp black-and-white you got
people like Bill Murray and Jeffrey
Jones playing Chris well like it's such
a crazy weird movie weirdly mine's a
black-and-white film - that's not really
a horror film um but this was probably
the first sort of monster film I've ever
seen when I was really young a bodega
Stella Meet
sign my dad adored this movie and I
would die laughing at this film and
because I was young I was also scared
there's some good spooky stuff in there
it introduced me to all the legendary
monsters the Wolfman Dracula hi they're
all looking in it is really cool I
thought and looking back on it I still
think it was like the definitive horror
comedy because it honored the fun spooky
scares of things like Dracula but it
also blended this Abbott Costello like
back and forth dynamic and slapstick
humor and it also spawned like a [ __ ]
ton more groupies from these guys I
think that it's seven more where they
met other Hollywood monsters but to me
this this is like one of those
unforgettable experiences I've ever had
being young it did scare me but it also
made me laugh and I think without it I
wouldn't have been so appeal to [ __ ]
totally forgotten food scream on this
list I was surprised you didn't really
forgot you're gonna do a quick runner-up
portion just um do you have any notable
runners uh runners up scream that's all
I'm gonna say okay I got a few uh
speaking of Tim Burton and Johnny Depp I
think Sleepy Hollow is terrific and I
watched that pretty much every Halloween
so I want to mention that a reanimate ER
is amazing his crazy Lovecraft or shadow
the vampire always comes to mind like a
not too you know coming out of that the
others I wanted to I wanted to include
the others yeah that's a great exercise
and just chilling gothic horror and then
things like saw like I'm a big soft fan
I didn't really find a place for it on
this list this time but you know I like
Saw movies a lot you know shout out to
repo the Genetic Opera because it's
scrappy and it's kind of a mess but I
just love that movie so much
all right guys what's our top ten list
what did you like our list what did you
not like on our list
what is your list put down whatever the
[ __ ] you want to talk about in the
comments you're new to the channel
subscribe did come up reject John social
media manager facebook.com slash blue
Mouse and the real rejects as well and
shout out to all the horror movie fans
who watch this channel
oh it's shout out to Jason lives that's
my favorite kid jason blum to jason blum
man he really needs some encouragement
right now his company is just sure one
they are not profiting at all no never
never never dreamed you like
$150,000,000 films
getting most expensive box office really
budget i believe is the term